my name is Barbara Massey I'm captain
Massey's sister
you killed my sister
cat I'm gonna tell you about my sister
can't wait 110 pounds 72 years old
there's nothing Kevin wouldn't do for
people
I want personally to choke you is he my
fingerprints on your neck
because it was unnecessary
you leave 200 miles to come to Buffalo
you don't even know any black people so
I will hurt you so bad
you ain't made me sick you got my family
crying I miss my sister every day I live
Three Doors Down forget you're gonna
come to that City and decide you don't
like black people man you don't know a
damn thing about black people we're
human we like our kids to go to good
schools we love our kids
Never Gonna Know neighborhoods and take
people out
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
but I am sure that you are all disturbed
by
the physicality that we've seen in the
courtroom here today and and I
understand that emotion and I understand
the anger
but we cannot have that in the courtroom
and I am prepared to give anyone that
needs to speak an opportunity to speak
um and I know that you need to address
some of your comments to the defendant
but we must conduct ourselves
appropriately
because we are all better than that